Sao nay ngày 20 năm năm 2019, bình Việt đã khoa thông nhất, tình đồng này, cho biết bình Việt vừa tiếp định nhóm
nằm bệnh đến của công việc của phần gệnh mêng phương năm. Xin yang đồng này,
của công việc ở rửa xe dừng tình an, sát tình an, phuyện vính cử, đi của được phí xe,
theo bảo kắng nhân của khoa cấp cứu bệnh Việt hai chừng vừa tử vóng ngoại vịt.
Nhi rong của được phí xe or là nửa lời s, bà mi tám tuổi, chú sát tình an, phuyện vính cử, tình đồng này,
và nửa hát vi lời hai mi sau tuổi, chú sát lạ an, phuyện bắt tình đuyền tình bình dược.
Bà chừng vực hám đăng tiếp tục được cấp cứu, đề xe hát bố mi tư tuổi, chú sát lạ an, phuyện bắt tình đuyền tình bình dược.
Nếu tế hát, bà mi tư tuổi, lâu viên nờ bố mi tụi, cùng chú sát tình an, phuyện vính cử, đồng này.
Ông lưu đứa khá, cán bộ an tỏng là đồng của công ty cho biết khoảng một giờ cùng này,
hiện được tông tin có năm người bị ngủ độc khi có, bố phận ít tế của công ty đa xe kí uống và chở những người này để cấp cứu tại mình vệnh đa qua tông nhất, vụ việc tiếp tục cấp nhật.